I've lived in Germany since I was little
I actually feel more German than polish
at home we spoke polish and we still do
at home things are very polish but my
everyday life outside of home has always
been very German community Carol Cathy
Itsuki was born in woods in Poland in
1981 the family moved to Germany when he
was just a few months old and he grew up
in the city of Kaiserslautern but he
also spent a lot of time with his
grandparents in wood
as a teenager
Kunal began an apprenticeship as a chef
but he didn't finish it he completed
vocational high school and studied
marketing and communication but his love
for cooking remained a major factor of
identity is culture since eating is
culture it is also a very big factor
your identity is connected to the sense
of taste and the sense of smell and that
all comes together in the kitchen and
food and so taste is a large part of
identity - Marcus definite lead entity
Carroll's restaurant is a purely Polish
affair serving up classic pierogi party
stews and soups
he gives the recipes of modern update
offers vegetarian and vegan variations
and experiments with the traditions of
Polish cuisine a visit to Poland
inspired him to open his deli tactic in
2015 my oppa Derick father offer money
please my favorite grandpa always loved
to cook and I spent a lot of time with
him during summer vacation I was always
traveling around with him in Poland and
he was a cook for the Navy grandpa was a
role model he always caught
fantastically very hearty very delicious
yeah I think that's part of where my
cooking comes from I'm following in my
grandpa's footsteps Zurich is a white
borscht salad with fermented flour that
poles traditionally eats at Easter it is
one of Carol's favorite dishes
his grandmother cooked it for him all
year round there are many ways to vary
this traditional soup Carol makes his
with lots of vegetables garlic is
ubiquitous in Poland
marjoram and Bailey's belong in almost
every dish to
and traditional Polish cuisine uses lots
of meat the most important ingredient in
Zurich is added last fermented course
rye flour which gives the soup its tang
and its name does erectus is a fermented
rice flour you just let it stand my
great-grandmother used to let it sit in
the Sun on the windowsill she would take
portions from I've tried to do that a
number of times but I've never managed
to have it come out right so for now I
buy it in a shop in memento of pathology
here for work Carol operates tactic in
Berlin's mitr district in the former
communist east of Berlin he says his
neighborhood reminds him of Poland
that's tough competition from the many
other nearby restaurants
[Music]
he set out to establish a stylish Polish
deli he designed the furnishings himself
and had them built to his specifications
the photo on the wall shows the
landscape on Poland's Baltic Sea coast
the deli went over so well from day one
that Carole is already planning to
expand to other German cities as well
[Music]
my family comes from Poland too so I'm
quite familiar with homemade pierogi
these come very close to the way my
grandmother made them it's wonderful
here you can try the classic varieties
but more unusual ones too hipster
pierogi that sums it up before Carl
Casillas key open tactic he conducted a
survey on the internet to learn what
people associated with Poland many said
a touch of melancholy and delicious
hearty foods
first dish I go to Valley schmooze
direct manage a receive ample power is
just not snake
[Music]